es ist eine barbarische botschaft von
putin an die westliche welt mitten
während des g 7 gipfels lässt er ein
einkaufszentrum in der ukraine
bombardieren flammen schlagen aus dem
gebäude in crimmitschau
zahlreiche verletzte mindestens 15
menschen sterben über 40 menschen werden
derzeit noch verletzt dass die sekunden
nach dem einschlag dort chaos panik
flammen er ist tief in die nacht wird
nach den vermissten gesucht zwischen den
trümmern und den flammen das sind die
ersten bilder vom einsatzort sie zeigen
dass das feuer mittlerweile etwas
eingedämmt werden könnte krementschouk
das ist eine industriestadt mit 217.000
einwohnern und standort der größte
ölraffinerie des landes die frage die
sich stellt ist natürlich auch weil die
raffinerie das eigentliche ziel oder
wollte putin genau dass das
einkaufszentrum bombardieren mit
möglichst vielen zivilen opfern noch in
der nacht machte sich paul ronzheimer
auf vor vom osten des landes circa 400
kilometer durch die ukraine und schickte
uns diese eindrücke
wir sind in crimmitschau dem ort der am
nachmittag zur heftig von russischen
raketen getroffen wurde und hier sieht
man die aufräumarbeiten aber noch sehr
viel sichtbarer wird es wenn man
reingeht das was einst eine
shoppingmeile war
wo die menschen einkaufen wollten wo sie
hingekommen sind um nahrungsmittel zu
kaufen und jetzt sehen wir hier
eine komplette zerstörung
immer noch sind feuerwehrmänner damit
beschäftigt hier aufzuräumen wir gehen
einfach mal hier in diese richtung
gleich durch man sieht man sieht wie
immer noch hier versucht wird auch
teilweise menschen zu finden haben uns
die rettungskräfte erklärt sowohl die
feuerwehr als auch rettungssanitäter
sind weiter hier vor ort wir gehen
einmal weiter durch man sieht hier noch
rauch und wir gehen einmal durch in
diese richtung
das sind typische szenen die sich hier
abspielen an dem ehemaligen supermarkt
der shopping mall hier die getroffen
wurde von russischen raketen man sieht
immer noch aufräumarbeiten es ist weit
nach mitternacht in diesem ort wir sehen
feuerwehrmänner wir sehen immer noch
rettungssanitäter immer noch werden
menschen gesucht ist hat etwas wenn man
sich umschaut von zähnen nach einer
großen katastrophe
etwas das sind dieser form in diesem
krieg und jetzt in diesem moment
wir müssen hier auch aufpassen
die ist in diesem krieg der form die ich
noch nicht gesehen habe
es sind fast unwirkliche bilder es ist
putins blutiger gruß einen gipfel der
mächtigen nur kurz zuvor war auch über
jenes präsident willi lenz gb 7
zugeschaltet forderte ein ende des
kriegs noch in diesem jahr für ihn ist
der angriff jetzt kein zufälliger
treffer
der heutige russische angriffe auf das
einkaufszentrum in grimmen schock ist
eine der furchtbarsten terrorakte in der
geschichte europas es ist eine
friedliche stadt es war ein gewöhnliches
einkaufszentrum frauen und kinder waren
darin gewöhnliche zivilisten vor den
luftangriff serien waren dort etwa 1000
menschen am shoppen glücklicherweise
gelangen vielen menschen die flucht sie
wurden gerettet aber es waren viele
menschen drinnen die nicht entkommen
konnten arbeiter viele besucher nur
absolute psycho terroristen die keinen
platz auf der erde rahmen sollten können
raketen auch ein solches objekt abfeuern
und das war kein zufälliger
raketentreffer es war ein präziser
russische angriff genau auf dieses
einkaufszentrum
von osten der ukraine vom don basis von
ronzheimer durch das land gefahren um
vom ort des geschehens vom
einkaufszentrum in crimmitschau zu
berichten eine fahrt quer durch das land
des krieges wie wir hier auch auf dieser
karte sehen können
eine gefährliche fahrt eine lange reise
400 kilometer und jetzt ist er uns
zugeschaltet manzano paul
das sind bilder bereits alle wonach
geschickt dort die aufräumarbeiten die
verzweifelte suche noch überlebende zu
finden jetzt an diesem morgen gibt es
noch die hoffnung dort übernehmen
patricia die anwohner die ich getroffen
habe die geben die hoffnung nicht
komplett auf es gibt noch vermisste
einige haben ihre menschen ihre freunde
ihre verwandte noch nicht wieder
gefunden vielleicht sind sie im
krankenhaus leicht sind sie aber auch
tot das sind die fragen die sich diese
stadt hier am morgen danach stellt am
morgen nachdem hier wo ich gerade stehe
menschen waren die einkaufen wollten und
die dann von der russischen rakete von
den russischen raketen getroffen wurde
es ist paul ein blutiger gruß mit bernd
g 7 werden die mächtigen der welt tagen
welchen gruß will putin da schicken
welche nachricht will putin mit diesen
angriff auf zivilisten auf frauen auf
kinder auf menschen die einkaufen gehen
wollten in die welt senden
eines ist ganz klar vertritt sie ja die
angriffe von wladimir putin von der
russischen armee haben massiv zugenommen
in den vergangenen tagen seit 47
gestartet ist wir haben den angriff in
kiew gesehen wir haben angriffe in
kharkiv gesehen natürlich im don bosco
der blutige vormarsch der russen jetzt
vielleicht mit deutschen waffen ein
bisschen gestoppt werden kann es ist ein
klares zeichen dass putin nicht bereit
ist zu verhandeln dass er nicht bereit
ist hier auf irgendetwas
an diplomatie zu tun ganz im gegenteil
und es ist das zeichen dass dieser krieg
noch brutaler wird und dieser krieg noch
sehr sehr lange dauern kann
wenn du sprichst paul sehen wir die
bilder dieses angriffs dieser brutalität
wieder sind zivilisten
die es trifft du bist auch quer durch
das land gefahren in der nacht eine
reise die durchaus gefährlich ist
welchen eindruck gewinnt so wie ist die
situation in der ukraine du sagst die
brutalität nimmt zu man fragt sich wie
kann das wie soll das alles weitergehen
fragen die sich ja durchaus auch die
mächtigen bei g7 stellen
[Applaus]
es war eine fahrt durch ein nervöses
land durch ein aufgegebenes land an den
checkpoints haben wir der böse soldaten
getroffen wir uns gefragt haben was
passiert hier gerade die auch nicht
wussten was ist dieser angriff auf ein
einkaufszentrum hier in grimmen schub wo
eigentlich der krieg kaum eine rolle
gespielt hat russland das muss man
dazusagen behauptet man habe in der nähe
ein militärisches ziel treffen wollen
man behauptet es habe hier in der nähe
eine militär fabrik gegeben das ist noch
nicht aufgeklärt sagt ist das wo ich
hier stehe keine panzer oder ähnliches
gefertigt wurden sondern dass das ein
einkaufszentrum war das getroffen wurde
hallo hans heimann mit dem neuesten
informationen aus der ukraine wo putin
ein einkaufszentrum bombardieren ließ
danke dir kommt
er wie kann der westen putin die stirn
bieten was muss geschehen damit dieser
krieg endlich endet und wie wird die
welt danach aussehen das sind die
entscheidenden fragen beim gipfel der
mächtigen der welt ein zurück zum
verhältnis mit russland wird es niemals
geben das machte jetzt olaf scholz beim
g7-gipfel klar
auf den krieg in der ukraine blicken wir
aus unterschiedlichen perspektiven das
wissen alle gerade deshalb ist es
wichtig dass wir miteinander darüber
sprechen und unsere jeweiligen
sichtweisen auch austauschen heute
vormittag hatten wir per video
zugeschaltet den ukrainischen
präsidenten seelands geber uns in der g7
runde zu gast der präsident hat noch
einmal sehr eindringlich die lage
geschildert wie sie sich für die ukraine
gegenwärtig darstellt
deshalb ist auch klar im verhältnis zu
russland kann es kein zurück geben in
die zeit vor dem russischen überfall auf
die ukraine denn wenn die lage sich
verändert müssen auch wir uns verändern
das wissen alle sehr genau und alle g 7
staaten sind dazu auch bereit die
notwendigen entscheidungen zu treffen